Press can help you achieve
your goals quickly.
You'll want to have writers and
tech magazines mentioning you to help
spread the word about your products.
If you can, getting a tweet, a public
donation, or a mention from a relevent
celebrity or peer leader who supports
your product can be a huge help.
Working with a peer firm
can be expensive, but
might be worth considering.
If you have a big bang launch,
like a KickStarter campaign or
any other specific launch date that
you want to create a big buzz around.
PR firms can help you get
big names supporters or
celebrities to promote your business.
However, if it's too early for
your start up to spend budget on PR,
you can always do it yourself.
If you choose to do it yourself,
you will want to start by writing
a paragraph that you
like writers to write,
if you could have them
write whatever you want.
This will help you clearly identify
how you want your company to be
presented in the press.
Check out the instructor notes for for
an article on tips on how to do this.
And let's see what Tali Saar has to
say about PR in the early stages of
a start up.
>> Hi, I'm Tali Saar,
I'm the founder and CEO of Rooster.
Before starting Rooster,
I spent four years at Google.
I was on the marketing team and
I was part of the founding team that
started a program called Google Engage,
which developed today into Google
Partners, which is a global program.
I left Google, I came to Silicon Valley,
and I was first employee for
a start up called Honey Book.
And then I started my company
Rooster a year and a half ago.
Rooster is a pay it forward movement.
We're building a local network that
brings people together to help, borrow,
and share with one another completely
for free in their local communities.
So the idea is you join Rooster in your
location, and you create a profile,
you have your real identity there,
and then the rules are you can ask for
whatever you need and help whenever
you can, but it has to be for free.
So people use it to hand down used
furniture and items they don't need,
like sofas, TVs, art supplies.
They borrow baseball bats and baby cribs
from one another, they walk each other's
dogs, they help each other fix their
bike chains and things like that.
We're currently launched in three cities
with thousands of users, and a lot of
them use it daily and meet each other,
and have all these great experiences.
Starting with PR with low budget.
It's funny a lot of start ups operate
under the assumption that doing PR
is this really complicated thing, and
you have to build personal connections
with all the reporters, and
you have to be in the scene so
that they'll want to write about you.
In my experience, not true at all.
PR and journalists,
their job is to get these stories.
And all you need to do is
understand their world and
where they're coming from and
know how to pitch them, and have
an interesting story to tell, right?
So you want to have a product
that's interesting enough,
you want to have some kind traction,
or some kind of story,
something that you know, can make a news
story and you'll know when you have it.
And then you just want to be very
thoughtful of the journalists' time.
So you want to research who your
journalists are that cover your space
that will potentially
be interested in this.
Don't go and
pitch a thousand irrelevant people.
And once you have those people,
just write in a very clear and
concise way and just consider that
they're getting hundreds of emails per
day and you have to grab
their attention first, right?
So just write a very compelling title,
write a very clear and concise pitch
about why this would be interesting
to them and just go and do it.
Go and reach out to all these people,
and in my experience,
I got great stories in local press and
in the tech countries of the world,
and everywhere I wanted just by giving
the right person the right story.